[Musique]
aujourd'hui au Sahel au Moyen-Orient et
à l'est de l'Europe hier en Afghanistan
et en Centrafrique depuis 60 ans la
France est engagée en opération
extérieure déployée au-delà de ses
frontières depuis plus d'un demi-siècle
pour assurer la sécurité des Français la
France est devenue par nature une
puissance expéditionnaire et les armées
en sont l'expression
en s'appuyant sur son réseau de force
prépositionnée de souveraineté les
armées sont en mesure d'intervenir sous
les cinq continents et pour répondre à
l'urgence quand la situation l'impose un
vecteur PEP figure d'un contournable
projection de puissance acheminement de
fret a pu à nos opérations évacuation de
ressortissants autant d'exemples qui
montrent sa nécessité et sa pertinence
embarquement immédiat au cœur du
transport aérien militaire
[Musique]
c'est l'une des pires crises de l'ordre
international que l'Europe est connu
depuis la fin de la guerre froide dans
la nuit du 24 février 2022 la Fédération
de Russie envahit l'Ukraine c'est
invasion provoque une condamnation
massive de la communauté internationale
France
condamne dans les termes les plus forts
le déclenchement de ces opérations pour
éviter que ce conflit se propage au-delà
des frontières de l'Ukraine dans les
pays membres de l'OTAN la France riposte
à l'agression russe en renforçant sa
participation au sein de l'Alliance
Atlantique à l'est de l'Europe
nation cadre de la porte de réaction
rapide de l'OTAN en 2022 la France
déploie quatre jours seulement après
l'agression russe ses premiers éléments
en Roumanie à Constanta au total ils
sont 500 militaires français acheminis
par voie aérienne a composé avec 300
belges le bataillon fer de lance de la
force de réaction rapide de l'OTAN mais
ce déploiement ne se limite pas à la
Roumanie la France mobilise son groupe
aéronaval en Méditerranée déclenchent
des missions de police du ciel en
Bulgarie et en Pologne poursuit ses
exercices au Tania de grande ampleur en
Norvège et prolonge sa présence en
Estonie
mi mars le septième bataillon de
chasseurs alpin se tient prêt
appartenant à la brigade d'urgence de
l'armée de terre cette compagnie
spécialiste du combat en montagne dans
des environnements grands froids et
mobilisés pour l'Estonie un jour un peu
particulier parce qu'on est à la veille
de d'une projection en Estonie une
entraîner pour tous types de mission et
là en particulier on sera dans notre
milieu donc je pense qu'on est prêt
bon globalement le rappel de la mission
il s'agit bien de dissuader d'accord
dissuader dans le cadre de la mission de
réassurance de l'OTAN donc il s'agit en
clair de montrer les les gros bras face
à qui vous savez la particularité de
cette mission c'est qu'elle intervient
dans un cadre multinational vous allez
être placé sous le commandement d'un
chef de corps qui est britannique à côté
de vous vous aurez des Danois et vous
serez en Estonie donc vous serez au
coeur de la mêlée ce que j'attends de
vous c'est très simple la rigueur la
sérénité et la détermination
peut-être un peu de d'excitation mais
aussi de l'appréhension bien sûr c'est
un départ aussi un petit peu incertain
avec les conditions sécuritaires qui
sont un petit peu dégradées en ce moment
au vu du contexte international où on va
charger nos sacs
ensuite on va partir en direction de
Paris ou prendre l'avion avec nos
camarades de l'Armée de l'Air on compte
sur nos camarades
me l'escadron de l'Estérel pour nous
amener justement sur nos différents tas
d'opérations sur lesquels on va
intervenir
c'est l'escadron de transport Esterel
goal qui acheminera avec leur
équipements ces chasseurs alpins en
Estonie direction terminale 2B de
l'aéroport Charles de Gaulle vous pouvez
voir le bus est plein à craquer donc
direction l'Estérel sans eux on peut
rien faire
4h15 du matin donc là comme vous avez vu
hein c'est toujours organisé donc là les
changements des sacs et après ensuite
embarquer dans l'avion
en parallèle de l'enregistrement des
chasseurs alpins l'équipage de
l'escadron de transport de l'Estérel en
barque pendant près d'une heure le
personnel navigant prépare l'aéronef
météo
le nombre de passagers et qui soit au
bon emplacements et puis aussi pour le
centrage de l'avion vous rendez compte
170 passagers se fait ça fait 17 tonnes
à peu près et si il y en a trop d'un
côté l'avion il sera pas centré et c'est
pas bon
aujourd'hui l'Estérel c'est deux avions
deux Airbus 330 comme celui-ci donc
c'est un Airbus comme vous pouvez le
voir dans les autres compagnies
aériennes mais il est utilisé pour les
militaires la mission principale c'est
le transport stratégique on achemine les
passagers au plus proche du théâtre
d'opération une mission typiquement
comment on fait aujourd'hui rejeter 170
passagers en Estonie et à droite la
projection à longue distance
représente 95% des missions de l'Estérel
reconnaissable à ces deux Airbus aux
couleurs de la République française cet
escadron n'a qu'une vocation projetée
vite et loin
[Musique]
de transport par deux adjectifs le
premier ça serait efficacité par la
charge offerte et puis aussi par le
rayon d'action et modernisme parce que
la 330 c'est un avion qui est récent et
la 330 MRTT c'est un avion qui est tout
récent
rattaché aux forces aériennes
stratégiques en 2021 l'escadron sera
transféré sur la base aérienne Distre en
2023 à terme ces Airbus A330 seront
améliorées pour être dotés de nouvelles
capacités comme celles du ravitaillement
vol
c'est ça qui est gratifiant c'est de
participer aux opérations dans les
déposant et quand on vient les
rechercher ils sont quand même contents
de retourner à la maison et on essaye de
leur donner un petit peu de bonheur avec
un café un bon plateau du sourire c'est
ça qui est gratifiant dans notre métier
aussi
si la guerre en Ukraine marque un retour
au stade la France est engagé sur un
autre front celui de la lutte
antiterroriste au Sahel
aujourd'hui l'opération barkhane est la
plus importante opération extérieure de
la France au plus fort de l'opération
5100 militaires français ils sont
déployés à travers cinq pays du Sahel
pour des mandats de 2 à 4 mois ainsi
plusieurs fois par an au cours de ce que
les armées appellent les relèvent il
faut acheminer et faire rentrer ses
hommes de l'opération barkhane chaque
année c'est près de 45000 soldats qui
transitent sur cette opération un défi
logistique hors normes où les aéronefs
de transport sont en première ligne
ici sur la base aérienne d'Istres
épicentre des flux entrants et sortants
des militaires déployés en opération
près de 200 militaires s'apprête à
rejoindre l'opération barkhane et plus
particulièrement le Niger
cet acheminement de personnel sera
effectué par un A330 MRTT Phénix le
dernier avion multirool de transport et
de ravitaillement en vol de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace
de gros terrain internationaux et puis
on peut faire la première connexion vers
le théâtre de variation extérieure et
ensuite il y a la flotte de transport
avec la 400m et les Casa qui eux peuvent
aller sur des endroits qui vous seraient
inaccessibles donc elle est complètement
complémentaire
l'armée de l'air elle est toujours
réactive
de dire qu'elle est capable de faire les
choses rapidement c'est bien la capacité
de pouvoir amener des gens partout dans
le monde et avoir une indépendance à ce
niveau là à mon sens c'est indispensable
après 4h32 vols ces hommes arrivent à
niamer sur l'opération barkhane la
plupart d'entre eux sera disséminée par
d'autres moyens aériens à travers la
bande saïlossaharienne certains iront au
Mali quand d'autres resteront au Niger
pour optimiser chaque vol alors que ces
militaires arrivent d'autres repartent
c'est la lieutenant Justine qui est à la
manœuvre
par le sas
donc on vous souhaite un bon vol et un
bon retour à Montauban
j'occupe aujourd'hui la fonction de chef
d'antenne J1 donc Gien c'est toute la
chaîne de gestion des effectifs on va
gérer tout ce qui est fuseau ouest de
l'opération c'est-à-dire le Niger et le
Mali ce qui représente environ la
gestion de 3000 personnels on va gérer
les personnels qui est en mission qui
doivent être relevées donc on accueille
leur relève pour qu'il y ait une
passation de consigne et après on va
gérer ceux qui doivent repartir vers la
métropole tous les vols transit
majoritairement par Niamey les gros
vecteurs on peut pas les faire poser
n'importe où donc niami c'est vraiment
le la plateforme logistique de tout ça
des arrivées des personnels personnels
mais également fret voilà faut pas
oublier que on a on a une partie gestion
des effectifs mais on a aussi une partie
gestion de fret donc tout le matériel
qui va pouvoir aussi permettre la
réalisation d'une mission
si tout semble fluide la bonne conduite
de cette opération d'ampleur a nécessité
anticipation et planification et là on a
le tableau avec l'ensemble des moyens
aériens qui sont disponibles pour qu'on
puisse effectuer notre mission donc on
retrouve notre MRTT notre gros porteur
pour les relèves van IN OUT et on a des
plus petits avions type Casa ou à 400m
c'est 130 J qui nous permettent
l'acheminement en infra-théâtre du fret
ou du PACS c'est la fonction du
capitaine Steve affectée en France au
Centre de soutien des opérations
aériennes l'organisme chargé de
l'acheminement du fret et du personnel
militaire français à travers le monde il
a conduit quelques semaines auparavant
une mission dite cinématique donc on a à
peu près une centaine de Pax qui
arrivent et 200 packs qui ressortent
cette mission a pour objectif de
planifier la relève de personnel de
l'ensemble de la force barkhane et donc
il faut construire cette cinématique de
relève personnel militaire français pour
pouvoir répondre à tous ces impératifs
de mission mais on a des forces
française qui sont basées partout dans
le monde et c'est un défi de projeter
tous ces personnels sur tous ces lieux
donc il y a une coordination qui est
indispensable pour pouvoir répondre aux
besoins de tout le monde
la contrainte majeure c'est clairement
les opérations c'est l'opérationnel
notre objectif c'est de répondre
toujours aux besoins des opérations
et sur un terrain escarpé difficile
d'accès et vaste comme l'Europe les
moyens aériens sont essentiels pour
appuyer les soldats en opération au plus
près des combats
sur le fuseau ouest de l'opération
barkhane trois aéronef tactiques sont
employés à cette tâche ils sont gérés
par le groupement de transports
opérationnels
le but du groupement transport
opérationnel c'est d'être un soutien
pour les opérations c'est son but
principal donc les avions ils ne sont là
que pour soutenir les opérations donc
pour ça on emploie ce qu'on appelle des
modes d'action tactiques qui peuvent
être de l'aéroportage c'est-à-dire
amener des personnels au plus proche du
combat sur des aérodromes
ça peut être de l'aéron largage de
personnel donc des parachutistes qui
vont sauter de l'avion et ça va être
enfin de l'aérolargage donc c'est à dire
directement acheminer au plus près des
troupes du ravitaillement de munitions
de carburant et de vivre dans la soute
de ce c130i Cesari meurs largers
spécialistes de la livraison par air
charge ses palettes en bois appelé
fardeau à destination d'un groupement
tactique engagé à la frontière
nigérienne depuis plusieurs jours on
règle générale sur l'opération barkhane
on va larguer des jours de vivre pour
les combattants au sol donc ce sera
principalement de l'eau des rations on
va aussi les ravitailler en gaz voile
parce que forcément les convois au sol
ont besoin de gasoil pour pouvoir
avancer et ensuite nous pouvons larguer
des pièces mécaniques des pneus des
démarreurs des batteries des munitions
tous les combattants tout ce qu'ils ont
besoin au sol on le conditionne et
ensuite on peut leur laurier tu
m'appelles
j'ai déjà inspecté la face avant
on laisse en fait 20 cm 20 cm d'espace
entre les deux charges là il est en
train de relier cette charge avec
celle-ci avec de l'adresse et c'est ce
qui va créer en fait les une seconde et
demi de cadencement c'est-à-dire que
nous en fait avec des AP un petit peu de
scotch et descendre on arrive à faire
quelque chose de magique l'opération de
la journée sera assez exceptionnel un
630 J et un A400M effectueront une
livraison par air simultanée
[Musique]
la partie du largage pour nous chef
largueur c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
il y a beaucoup de préparation en amont
on va conditionner le matériel on va
faire la prise en compte de l'aéronef
chargé l'aéronef faire toutes les
vérifications et effectivement une fois
qu'on a décollé tous enchaîne très très
vite et en moins de 30 minutes nous
avons ravitaillé les troupes au sol
[Musique]
ce largage permettra aux 270 soldats
engagés au sol de continuer leur
opération mais la manœuvre n'est pas
terminée après cet aérolargage place à
l'aérotransport alors que le c130j
rentre à Niamey la 400 m poursuit son
vol vers Gao Mali pour embarquer trois
véhicules blindés légers
c'est des petits véhicules blindés et un
peu de matériel sur des palettes
on va aller livrer ça à Abidjan en fait
la route continue
cette avion il est parfait pour les
opérations parce qu'ils nous permet de
brosser un peu tout le SCOP des
capacités qu'on doit mettre en œuvre ça
peut être du largage de personnel du
largage de matériel de la mise à terre
par poser lassaut ça va être du
transport logistique ça va être de
transport de chargement particulier
comme les hélicoptères qui ne rentrent
pas dans les autres avions donc c'est
vraiment l'avion parfait pour ça
et je suis fier de toujours pouvoir
voler tous les jours dessus et continuer
à prendre du plaisir il est possible que
ça passe pas si ça passe pas en longueur
ou le lieu de chaîne sur l'année 2021
vous avez globalement de l'ordre de 2000
heures de vol vous avez l'ordre de 5200
tonnes de frais de transporter de
l'ordre de 400 tonnes largués en
opération de ravitaillement par air et
vous avez de l'ordre de 19000 passagers
transportés donc ce qui est un volume
considérable en intra-théâtre mais les
missions de la flotte de transport ne
s'arrête pas là des avions ravitailleurs
sont également mobilisés comme ceci 135
en permanence il intervient en soutien
des avions de chasse
ça a été mission de 4 heures de vol pour
pouvoir habiter un patrouille de D2000
qui ont effectué des missions de
réassurance de protection qu'on voit et
de recherche de formation reconnaissance
d'axes a pu départ ce spécial engagé au
sol démonstration de force et
surveillance aérienne pour un seul et
même vol différentes missions sont
prévues pour les mirages et pour les
mener à bien ces deux chasseurs ont
besoin d'autonomie pour pouvoir voler
plus longtemps pendant cette phase de
ravitaillement 9 tonnes de carburant
sont délivrés à ces deux chasseurs en
moins de 15 minutes
avec une autonomie de trois heures à 3h
dans notre environnement et ce qui
permet de rallonger le temps de vol des
chasseur de 4 à 5h de route
dans le ciel de barkhane les aéronefs de
transport sont des indispensables qu'il
s'agisse d'acheminer les soldats sur
l'opération ou bien de leur permettre
dans la durée de mener à bien leur
mission mais pour faire face aux
nouvelles menaces toutes ces capacités
nécessitent d'être entretenues et
toujours un peu plus amélioré
la recherche et l'innovation sont donc
essentielles pour rester à la pointe et
ce avec un seul mot d'ordre la réussite
des opérations
et en matière d'aérotransports
fait figure de référence basée près de
Toulouse le centre de la Direction
générale de l'armement dédiée aux
techniques aéronautiques à notamment
pour vocation d'évaluer la capacité d'un
matériel à être aérotransporté et ici le
recours aux nouvelles technologies est
un prérequis ingénieur Yoann est expert
simulation dans le domaine de
l'aérotransport avec son équipe il a
développé Vesta un nouvel outil pour
faciliter le chargement de véhicules
dans les aéronefs comme le blindé
multiro légers
[Musique]
comme par exemple le calcul de charge
aux essieux les distances de sécurité et
les limitations avion entre les deux
salles on a un espace très restreint
et du coup il a fallu quand même trouver
une solution pour arrimer
enfin pour respecter les valeurs
d'arrimage sur les nos deux cervelles
enfin la réalité virtuelle nous permet
de nous immerger vraiment dans nos
simulations et de
visualiser précisément les encombrements
des différents matériels qu'il y a dans
la soute donc Vesta à nous a permis
d'obtenir un gain de précision en termes
de visuel de représentation visuelle de
nos simulations mais aussi en termes de
calculs qui sont plus précis maintenant
on estime à 30% le gain de temps
obtenu pendant la réalisation des essais
sur le serveur par exemple
[Musique]
sylvesta fait ses preuves avec le serval
il est promis un bel avenir en venant
prêter main forte à d'autres domaines
d'expertise comme celui de
l'aéroccordage et de l'aéron largage
si cette technologie de pointe tient une
part grandissante dans les essais et les
qualifications de matériel militaire la
confrontation réelle reste néanmoins
nécessaires et essentiel
ressemblons à un gros quad le fardier
est un nouveau véhicule pouvant
transporter et tracter l'équipement de
personnel parachutés il est en phase de
qualification d'aérolargage
on va s'attacher à deux choses la
première c'est qu'il puisse être larguer
en toute sécurité et la seconde qu'il
puisse arriver au sol entier et
conserver toutes ses performances
puis après on va vérifier que lors du
largage le véhicule arrive au sol et
puisse être des conditionné rapidement
et qui soit opérationnel c'est à dire
que les fantassins qui l'accompagnent
puissent monter à bord et partir dans
des délais assez bref
les forces françaises sont vulnérables à
être dotées d'une force aéroportée
majeure et opérationnel et le véhicule
fermier a été spécifiquement conçu pour
être aérolargué et soutenir les troupes
aéroportées sa vocation est d'amener du
matériel en soutien en flottassin mais
aussi d'évacuer du blessé ou de
transporter du matériel son dernier
essai réussi il devrait entrer dans les
forces fin 2022 pour notamment faire
équipe avec la 401 pour soutenir
parachutiste ou fantassin en première
ligne
et être en première ligne s'apparente
parfois à répondre le plus rapidement
possible à l'imprévu
après une offensive éclair qui aura duré
trois mois et demi l'Afghanistan tombeau
main d’état Liban le 15 août 2021 le
mouvement islamiste entre dans la
capitale afghan Caboul des milliers
d'avant cherche à fuir le nouveau régime
leur seul échappatoire l'aéroport de
Kaboul encore sécurisé par les
Américains dont le retrait définitif est
annoncé le 31 août
pour la France une course
contre-la-montre s'enclenche pour
évacuer notamment ses ressortissants une
manœuvre logistique d'envergure est
alors déclenchée l'opération à Pagan
depuis Paris au centre de planification
et de conduite des opérations le colonel
cyril a préparé et suivi en temps réel
le bon déroulement de l'opération
en termes logistique une évacuation de
ressortissants n'est jamais simple et
elle est forcément conditionnée à la
géographie du pays l'Afghanistan c'est
un pays enclavé donc on n'arrive pas par
la voie maritime il y a forcément soit
de la voie aérienne soit de la voie
terrestre lorsqu'il faut aller vite la
voyelle évidemment la plus appropriée
les principaux atouts dont la France
dispose sont son dispositif d'alerte
engagement national d'urgence en 48
heures ou 24 heures n'importe où dans le
monde sont évidemment ces moyens de
projection aériens et ensuite son réseau
de force prépositionnées ou de force de
souveraineté qui permet d'avoir des
relais logistiques des puis un peu
partout dans le monde seulement quelques
heures après la chute de Kaboul deux
avions de transport tactique de type
C130 Hercule et A400 et matelas pose sur
le tarmac de la base aérienne 104 d'Abu
Dhabi et puis centre des forces
françaises prépositionnées aux Émirats
arabes unis cette base sera le pivot de
l'opération
un double pont aérien est mis en place
ces aéroned de transport tactique
assureront les évacuations de Kaboul
vert Abu Dhabi alors que les avions de
transport stratégique de type A310 et
A330 MRTT feront la liaison entre les
Émirats Arabes Unis et la France le
choix de sporter sur les avions de
transport tactique à 400 ou 630 Hercule
c'est fait parce qu'on avait la
possibilité d'avoir un point relais sur
les forces françaises aux Émirats arabes
unis le temps de vol entre les eau et
l'Afghanistan et d'environ 3h30 à 14h30
en fonction du vecteur et un
aller-retour est possible sans avoir
besoin de réapprovisionner en carburant
donc c'est cette contrainte logistique
qui finalement a dimensionner
l'échelonnement de notre opération les
avions de transport stratégique quant à
eux ont été réservés au segment Emirats
Arabes Unis France parce que c'est de
l'avion longue distance parce qu'il y a
7 heures de vol parce qu'on met 250
personnes dedans au lieu de 70 et donc
de ce fait c'était beaucoup plus adapté
pour ce qu'on appelait les boucles
arrières les boucles avant étant faites
deux à trois fois par 24 heures sur
l'aéroport de Kaboul à bord de son A400M
le lieutenant-colonel Guillaume lui
était en première ligne au cœur du mois
d'août 2021 il a participé au dernier
évacuations de Kaboul une capitale en
proie une pression sécurité toujours
plus pesante on a cherché à essayer
d'emmener le plus de monde possible donc
on a pu dépasser le nombre de passagers
qui est normalement certifié sur A400M
en mettant des procédures un petit peu
particulières donc tout simplement tout
le monde n'avait pas de siège mais on a
pu tendre des sangles qui ont permis en
fait à embarquer le plus de monde
possible en toute sécurité et pouvoir
ramener tout le monde à bon port sur les
Émirats fin août c'est l'ébullition dans
la capitale afghan chaque jour les
afgans sont toujours un peu plus
nombreux à se masser aux portes de
l'aéroport mais intervenir dans cet
environnement dégradé en coalition sur
des pistes surchargées et perché à 1800
mètres d'altitude représente un vrai
défi pour les pilotes de transport les
équipages mettaient en oeuvre des
procédures d'approche et de décollage
particulière pour essayer de se
soustraire à une menace qui aurait pu
viser les aéronefs et finalement arriver
à s'intégrer aussi au sein d'une
coalition a été le principal enjeu au
sein de cette opération car pour évac le
plus de monde possible avant le 31 août
date de retrait des troupes américaines
les pilotes français ont dû s'insérer
dans un flux incessant d'avions
américains britannique canadien allemand
belge ou encore espagnol on avait une
demi-heure entre le poser et le
redécollage pour pouvoir faire nos
opérations d'embarquement débarquement
des opérations qui étaient réalisées
moteur tournant on n'avait pas la
possibilité également de refaire un
complément de carburant c'était des
contraintes tactiques assez fortes et
qui ont été dimensionnantes pour le la
conduite de cette opération au total 26
rotations entre Kaboul et Abu Dhabi et
16 entre les Emirats Arabes Unis et la
France auront lieu en seulement 13 jours
d'opération plus de 2800 ressortissants
français européen et afghan ont pu être
évacués voir sauvés
c'est une mission qui donne beaucoup de
sens à notre engagement la devise de la
brigade de aérienne des plus projection
et combattre et sauver et je pense que
en fait dans le cas de cette opération
on est clairement sur ces deux piliers
on se retrouve à opérer dans un
environnement dans lequel seul les
avions de transport militaire peuvent
opérer tout en ayant le la dimension
sauvetage de vie humaine et je pense que
à l'issue de cette opération on peut
être fier de ce qu'on a réalisé en
disant qu'on a sauvé sûrement plusieurs
vies ou en tout cas offert à nos horizon
des perspectives meilleures aux
personnes qu'on a pu embarquer plutôt
que s'ils étaient restés sur sur Kaboul
alors c'est une opération qui est hors
norme ça restera dans dans l'histoire de
l'aéronautique tout simplement parce
qu'en fait les ponts a rien sont
finalement assez peu nombreux depuis le
début de l'aéronautique et
l'aéronautique militaire finalement la
machinerie qu'on arrive à mettre en
oeuvre fait qu'on a une boucle de
décision très courte des moyens dédiés à
disposition en régie et en alerte qui
permettent n'importe où dans le monde
dans un temps très court et c'est ça qui
est rassurant ça c'est clairement une
sorte d'assurance vie que la France
offre assez concitoyens
projeté avec force vite et loin sont les
maîtres mots de la flotte de transport
française
reposant aussi bien sur des moyens
longue distance que sur des aéronefs
capables de poser sur des terrains
sommaires elle contribue depuis plus de
60 ans a donné à la France les moyens de
ses ambitions et de ses responsabilités
en matière de défense et de sécurité
dans un monde toujours un peu plus
dangereux où les crises prolifèrent de
l'Europe au Moyen-Orient et où les
distances se raccourcissent le transport
aérien militaire français constitue plus
que jamais un levier de puissance et de
diplomatie
[Musique]